so um well I mean Rebecca what do you
think of the you know in principle of
bringing these things onto one database
I think it's fantastic I think
transparency is long overdue of course
we've got our register of financial
interests but it only go so far in
shining a spotlight on where donations
come from and to what extent MPS are
remunerated for outside activities yeah
now we've got we will very shortly have
all your
registered donations and so forth on the
screen most of it I think has to be said
I think you're 11th on the list tomorrow
I've been saying over 400 000 most of it
from the unions in in your case I think
momentum as well
this was for the leadership
um campaign I mean that's a lot of money
from the unions do you think broadly
speaking and they get value for money
they certainly do and I think it's
important to note that when we were
going through the labor leadership
campaign I wanted to shine a spotlight
on party donations and I asked all of
the other leadership candidates to
publish their donors list before they
were expected to do so by the party
because I think it's important for our
members and our constituents to
understand who funds these campaigns
because that shines a light on what kind
of MP you are and what kind of leader
you were meant to be in the future and
of course I was proud that all of my
donations came from trade unions and
labor members who believed in what I was
setting out as a vision they wanted
proper rights for workers decent living
wage and to tax the super rich fairly so
that we could fund our Public Services
properly and it's also important to know
on the issue of Trade union donations
that they are the cleanest money that
can be found in politics they come from
democratic member-led organizations the
same can't be said of certain other
donations that are made to various MPS
that come from particular companies or
particular individuals who have certain
private interests money from individuals
and companies is not clean money I mean
it's it's not to say it's not clean
money but it comes with strings attached
should we say so trade unions donate to
the labor party because they set up the
labor party it's what we all believe in
is a Trade union movement for particular
individuals and particular organizations
there could be strings attached so for
example Rishi soon act received 530 000
pounds as part of his leadership
campaign over a quarter of that came
from oil gas companies and Aviation
individuals with particular interests
now there are no details as to what they
expected from the Prime Minister when he
became prime minister but of course the
question needs to be asked is as to why
we haven't seen the real action required
on the energy crisis why action hasn't
been taken it's just stringently enough
on the super profits of big energy
companies and why we're not seeing the
action on climate change that's needed
all right look I just want to stick on
this issue at the moment and on second
jobs Kia stormers seems to be quite
clear that he wants to ban second jobs
he doesn't seem very clear about the
instant of David Lammy who has money
coming in from speeches and media work
and so forth he didn't seem very clear
at all about whether he should be
stopped doing this work
so what is his view what is his view
what is your view oh my own personal
view I mean I don't receive any external
earnings outside my mp salary and I
think that being an MP is a hugely
privileged position to be in there
aren't enough hours in the day to do
your job as an MP properly let alone
take on a second job so I would ban
second jobs and I think Kia was right to
say that now in terms of ambiguity shall
we say there are arguments that are put
forward that certain individuals should
be allowed to keep up the professional
qualifications I was a lawyer I chose
not to do that because I wanted to give
my all to my job as an MP and I
sacrificed my old career to concentrate
solely on this one but if you're a nurse
for example I don't think there's a an
argument to say that you couldn't in
your holidays for example go in and help
out at your local a e department but
when that becomes a diversion to your
job as an MP it's not right so I would
go forward saying that we need to ban
jobs second jobs for MPS categorically
Sam just following up on that so do you
think kirst armor should tell David
Lammy to